in fact even as i speak john lester has
emerged from the washington first base
dugout and is heading out to the home
plate area
for another
ceremony
ian
anthony rizzo hugs around into pool
gifts memories from 2016 and six great
years
with the cubs john lester in the house
as you think about zach davies facing
these nationals what comes to mind well
first and foremost is establishing his
fastball
and for me pitching inside a little bit
too
back up the middle and behind second is
horny
they get the fleet-footed trey turner
in the air out to center coming on his
hat and he's there to make the grab
there's two down the 3-2
line i want to play rizzo
stretching out and making the grab oh my
goodness gold glove indeed
patrick corbin career against chicago 11
starts for different ball clubs five and
three with a good three one nine earned
run average
well patrick has been very good as of
late
that one minded a base hit out of the
left center field
jb reaching out poking that one into
left center for a knock
he goes fastball turner backhand
gonna have to be quick
and they were more than quick
maybe he's a quick worker the 1-1
wrapped on the ground to short scooped
up by baya's kind of a tricky hop but he
negotiated it cleanly and made the play
throwing to first out number one
hitting the air out towards right center
and right there is chris crimes
ground ball wide of third glove by bodhi
going to his left side arm flip throw to
second there's the force that's the
enemy
here's a bouncer back to the mound
corbin has it throws to first in time
and that's out number one
[Applause]
should be another double play ball
turner
right in the middle
patrick corbin living on the ground
tonight and that's fine all six outs the
results of ground balls
joe walsh had one of the greatest lines
i've ever heard
and i'm gonna remember it and here's a
pop-up playable for rizzo over near the
mound and he loves
it
next pitch tap third base side davies
throws him out
that one in there got him looking
and zimmerman down on strike's first
strikeout of the night for either
pitcher minutes second and third one
away no score in the game and wilson
cone turns with the infield back
on the ground right side through base
hit bodhian to score
and it's a two-run single wilson
contreras comes through two nothing
opposite our dugout there goes the
runner he had a great jump
gomes how about that throw they're going
to call him safe
and josh harrison thinks
the nat's got contreras there
great job by josh harrison here putting
the tag on him
and if they mess this one up in new york
i'm going to be pretty surprised
and they have reversed the call
that's a 2-4 caught stealing time called
david ross
wants to come out and are they going to
see about is it anthony rizzo i think
anthony's
i don't know if he's banged up or you
know if he's having so now we know
in years past he's had
on occasion some some back issues
on the ground to first and rizzo not
able to make the play picking it up yeah
that kind of the the move he made on
that ball leads you to believe that it's
still barking a little bit he has low
back tightness the cubs have reported
and was removed as a precaution
down and in with the slider
boy that's a great slider corbin is two
strikeouts of the night in that inning
davey sets at the belt he kicks and
delivers roe bliss lines one right into
the glove of bodhi who makes the catch
two away man on second for the nationals
and the leadoff man trey turner
tailing fastball bases gomes coming
around speeding home haps throw cut off
and trey turner is the man rbi number 22
and the gnats are on the board zimmerman
is one for two
that's a pitch up zimmerman to left
trey turner coming around no contest and
this game is tight
back up the middle base hit
harder around third they're going to
hold them up robles dropped it
after the single by contreras just one
away here in the fifth inning and it'll
bring up chris bryant the 2-2 to bryant
ground ball in the hole diving stop it
squirts off the glove of turner and the
cubs take the lead horner scores is
sterling castro trying to buy a hit the
1-1 from davies is cracked to deep
center field back on this one half to
the warning track looking up at the wall
and it is gone
starlin castro ends his 0 for 21 skid
with a blast over the center field wall
that ties the game
body one for two had an infield single
and scored one of the cubs runs
[Applause]
gives the cubs the lead puts a charge
into one
out there to left center field and it
comes on top it is now five
three
and now the tying runs are aboard
tapper third base side steal
weighted blows the first and it's dug
out by bryant and they get out of it two
were aboard and back to the top of the
order and trey turner dan winkler ready
in the 2-2 pitch turner hits a bouncer
back to the mound winkler has it throws
to first in time
tap hit into a double play walked and
struck out
in the air out towards left center
going back is schwarber near the road
it's into the basket home run here
and the cubs had a run it is 6-3
ball gets away and then it ricochets
and the gnats get a 90 foot gift as
zimmerman reaches on the strikeout the
2-2 from kimbrell
schwarber strikes out swinging on a high
fastball two down
on the ground to the right side horner
collects throw the first ball game comes
win
and it comes back over 500 with a 6-3
win